um so you you now have more family
members been on the show now I know how
it going we have two new little babies
it's crazy it's wild I I love it's
chaotic obviously um Ren is six he just
turned six months or sorry seven months
and Essie just turned a year and that
you know that that small difference is
all the is huge when they're that tiny
um and Luna and miles are just like
immersed in activities and so many
different things and everybody's got at
this different stage as a parent is very
hard oh my God the Girl Scout stuff the
we're in cookie season you want them to
be engaged that's me too but then it's
just like there's no way to feasibly
make all of these things and I asked
them I say yeah what is one activity we
should remove and miles is always like
tennis he doesn't like tennis cuz it's
too like one-on-one he can't get away
with any of his bull crap and then uh
with Luna she's like nothing and this
one she does everything that's my
daughter same thing um well esie just
turn one and there were some photos from
her birthday like this one
yeah you're like like this one that's
the old y'all make the cutest no y'all
make the cutest children ever they're so
beautiful wait and then there's this one
this one's fun
what it seems expensive what was broken
it was immediately after I honestly
don't know because that is a rental home
and so then I realized that they're
probably going to see that or they're
they saw it for sure um but yeah my
reflex time like I used to just like
with Luna like oh I would have it would
I would have caught that in a second
this one I watched it Go
Bo and then I just let it happen yeah
yeah that's having more than one kid
you're like it's fine the worst is how
proud she was after she she usually like
they cry like oh I just yeah she's just
she's our tough cookie oh that yeah I
get it girls girls and boys they're so
[Music]
different
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home